-Our next guest is
the White House corresponden
for "PBS News Hour."
Please welcome to the show
Yamiche Alcindor.
How are you, Yamiche?
-I'm doing well in this new life
that we're living.
-We are actually used to -
I should say I'm used to
seeing you out.
I'm used to seeing you at
White House press conferences.
It is nice to also
see you inside.
How has this been, going t
White House press conference
during this situation?
-It's been incredibly,
incredibly sobering.
This is, of course,
a scary and wild time.
So every day as I leave
my house, I'm putting on a mask.
I'm wiping my hands.
And I'm also, of course,
balancing the normal things I do
every day, which is making sur
I know what questions
I want to ask and what sources
I want to check in with.
So it just seems like there'
this added level of seriousnes
and craziness to what was
already a sort of crazy
political time I would say
in the last three years.
-Now, of course, one thing
a journalist doesn't want to d
is become part of the story.
You've been put in a awkward
situation whereas you've asked
very fair questions that the
President has framed as nasty.
He's told you to be nice
and to not be threatening.
What is going through your min
in those moments
where you realize
you are a part of this story
as opposed to just
getting the story?
-What's going through my mind is
that I became a reporter
because I think everyday people,
vulnerable populations,
deserve a voice,
especially at the White House.
So as the President may be
lashing out at me
and other reporters,
the thing I keep thinking is
"Okay, but people need answers
We're in this time where peopl
want to know, 'Can I get a test?
Am I going to be
able to survive?
How's my family going to d
when we're losing our jobs?'
I think all of those thing
come to my mind.
And in my own mind
think of myself
as a civil rights reporter
so a lot of times
I'm thinking about
all the different people
I've met over my career
on the streets
and on different stories
and thinking they need answers
They want me to remain
professional and focus on
why I came to
the White House today.
-I want to compliment you
for the fact
that you keep your poise
in those moments.
I don't believe
I would be able to do so.
When you get home, do you vent
Is there a time that you get out
those moments?
-Well, I'm lucky because I got
married about two years ag
and I run home to this cute bo
that lives with me
and I decompress with
my husband.
I talk about my day.
But I also do things like listen
to Bill Withers on repeat
and remember that there are so
many better days ahead of us
and that everyone should kind of
decompress and calm down.
So I personally really tak
the time to dance around
my apartment and to just talk to
my husband.
And that's the way
that I've had to --
that's the way I've been able to
weather all of this.
-I think a lot of us
have found that we're luck
to have families in times like
this to create a cushion
for the moment
we are going through.
Can you just speak -- you know
because obviously,
you've been covering this stor
like your colleagues
from the beginning.
Can you speak to what you
believe the root causes ar
for not just how this started --
and no one thinks it's the
current administration's fault
that, you know,
this virus exists --
but their failures
to sort of deal with it.
What the root causes
of that were?
-I think there were two
really big things going on
The first is that the President,
before this coronavirus
outbreak,
he was making government
smaller in his mind.
And in that regard he disbande
the National Security Council'
office that
deals with pandemics.
He also really pared down
the CDC's staff.
So there was one moment where --
or one thought
that the President was reall
making sure the government
was smaller in his mind.
The other thing that was
going on, though,
that was President Trump
was downplaying the virus.
He was telling reporters like me
and signaling to Americans
all over the country
that this was something
that wasn't that serious,
that it was going to
be gone by April,
that this was going to be
some sort of miracle
that was gonna
just be washed away.
And because of that, you had
those two things come together
And now that's why you hav
a lot of people
criticizing the President'
response,
because, one, they didn't seem
to be ready for a pandemic
and, two, the President, onc
a pandemic was on his doorstep
was downplaying it,
thinking really about
his political future
in a lot of regards,
and thinking about being
re-elected as President.
-One of the strange things
that we've seen
as these press conferences
get longer
is you have a situation
not just that the Presiden
will contradict himself
day to day,
he sometimes
will contradict himself
within the body of
an hour-long press conference.
Is it refreshing, then, to hav
someone like Dr. Anthony Fauci
on the dais
who's a bit more consistent?
And is it true
that you have spoken to hi
directly through this?
-I have spoken to Anthony Fauc
directly.
There was a day where there wa
some stories about him
being excluded
from the White House briefings
so I contacted his office,
and he actually called me back
which was pretty surprising.
And the first time he called m
back I didn't pick up the phon
because I thought he was
literally a prankster.
And then I eventually
called him back.
And of course his voice
is very, very distinct,
so I knew it was him.
But he was stressing to me
that his relationship
with the President
is really good
and that he's focused on doing
the work of the people.
I think it's refreshing in som
people's minds to, of course
have scientists who are expert
to talk about this.
There is, of course,
the fact that the Presiden
constantly contradicts himself
And that's why as a reporter
I often ask the President,
"Look, you said this
but you are now saying this.
How do you square that?"
The President sometimes
gets mad at that.
But I think it's doing a service
to people to be able
to point out every single day,
as much as you possibly can,
that the President
often not only shares
misleading information
but contradicts himself,
sometimes within minutes.
-You mentioned you're
a civil rights reporter.
That's where you began.
These are the sort of storie
you cover.
We've been seeing more and mor
in recent weeks
that this is disproportionally
affecting minority communities
Is there -- Do you have
any optimism or any sense
that there's a plan within
the White House to address that?
-As of now they're signaling
that they don't have a plan.
But it's also because they don't
actually have the data
to even create a plan.
Lawmakers have been pushing fo
federal data to be collected
and then shared when it comes to
looking at
the racial disparities.
We know that black people
in most cities and states
around the country are dying
because they have more
underlying conditions
like asthma and diabetes.
And part of that is systemic
racism and the conditions
that African-Americans
often live in this country
But I think that there isn't a
this point a particular plan
And Dr. Anthony Fauci
talked about this.
And he said
they're collecting the dat
and once they have
information to share,
they'll be able to
share more about that.